pub
berlin que partageaient une ligne
officielle mais idéal ville de voir
tomber entre ces deux zones le rideau de
fer
ce natale à berlin s'est éveillé au
bruit des marteaux-piqueurs it well as
tard dans la nuit le gouvernement de
bangkok pour enrayer l'hémorragie des
populations vers l'allemagne de l'ouest
qui en dix ans lui avait enlevé deux
millions d'âmes avait décrété la
fermeture des communications entre les
deux zones et sur 40 km de longueur
ces 40 km par lesquels on pouvait encore
choisir la liberté la barrière
s'établissait rues barrées pont barré
métro arrêtée
il ne restait sur ses 40 km que 18
points de passage le contrôle et essais
vers l'allemagne de l'est ce cadenassait
[Musique]
oh
le maire de berlin ouest monsieur willy
bram était venu se rendre compte par
lui-même de l'herméticité du système que
seuls des harnais une vingtaine de
transfuges parvenait à traverser chaque
jour ils pouvaient voir à la porte de
brandebourg symbole de la séparation des
deux berlin les chars des vopos prendre
position un authentique rideau de fer il
allait maintenant l'allemagne de l'est
[Musique]
les commandements alliés avaient
naturellement réagi immédiatement en
protestant auprès des autorités
soviétiques et en assurant le maire de
berlin monsieur willy brandt de leur
soutien est venu de washington le vice
président des états unis monsieur lyndon
johnson assure est à la foule berlinoise
les etats unis connaissent leur
engagement et sont décidés à accomplir
tous leurs devoirs
il ne représentait le général de sus
clair l'homme du pont aérien des heures
troubles de 1948 qui venait de réclamer
son poste à berne en même temps renfort
symbolique sans doute mais significatif
15 cents soldats américains avec 250
véhicules avaient franchi la frontière
et ouvrant sans encombre les 150 km du
couloir routier de bronze vie qu'à
berlin faisaient leur entrée aux
acclamations de la foule
les derniers groupes de réfugiés irait
grossir les rangs de ceux dont la fuite
était pour le gouvernement ou le riche
une sorte de condamnation berlin
maintenant était coupée en deux sans
fissures il y aurait tous les jours du
côté de l'est des groupes immobile
devant les barbelés mais la police de
l'est et là elle a l'oeil sur ces groupe
d'allemands quête d'espoir par dessus
ces barrières deux mondes se regardent
et attendent le coeur serré
[Musique]